rejoindre car le vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste et infectiologue du
québec monsieur vice bonjour monsieur
valls
on l'a vu aujourd'hui le docteur arruda
porter un masque pour la première fois
la mairesse de montréal valérie planta
nombre en portant depuis déjà quelques
jours on va distribuer des masques
gratuitement dans les autobus et les
métros j'aimerais vous entendre
est-ce qu effectivement il est utile
pour la population en général les
travailleurs qui vont tranquillement
revenir là au boulot de porter le masque
que ce soit dans la rue ou dans les
transports en commun qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
affecté c'est très personnel sur moi je
pense très efficace ça fait déjà des
semaines que je les dis pratico pratique
vous regardez ce qui se passe dans tous
les autres pays du monde les masques
sont utilisés dans la plupart des pays
occidentaux en asie au moyen orient dans
des pays d'afrique du nord depuis déjà
pas mal de temps
le mas tout seul en lui même n'est pas
une panacée mais le mas d'ajouter tous
les autres moyens est définitivement un
outil important dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus donc c'est très clair qu'il
fallait déjà je vous tirer rapidement en
semaine à ce qu'on appelle le mas
universel d'ailleurs même dans certains
hôpitaux ça fait déjà un bout de temps
qu'on a instauré le port du masque
universel pour tous les employés tous
les patients et c'était totalement
normal et évident dans le contexte
actuel où on a pas de vaccin on n'a pas
de médicaments profil m6 prévenir la
fiction d'utiliser tout ce qui est à
notre disposition
surtout dans une stratégie de
déconfinement et surtout ce qu'on sait
avec ce virus entre autres par rapport
aux gens qui seraient porteurs de façon
asymptomatique que le masque deviennent
finalement un outil normal faut
comprendre que culturellement en
amérique du nord en europe de l'ouest
les gens ne sont pas habitués à porter
des masques en asie c'est très fréquent
depuis très longtemps donc ça peut
paraître un peu étrange
les gens n'aiment pas ça peut-être qu'il
ya certaines personnes que saint etienne
donc il est hors de question légitime
qu'on peut se poser
mais d'un autre côté je vous dirais que
dans l'état actuel des choses surtout
avec notre épidémie à montréal si on
veut gagner la bataille
il faut faire feu de tout bois bon là il
ya un phénomène important et dangereux
dans une certaine
juste est peut-être un des effets
pervers de ce de ce confinement c'est à
dire que des gens qui sont malades et
qui hésitent qui hésitent à consulter
qui hésitent à se rendre dans des
hôpitaux
alors selon vous la est ce qu'on est en
train de créer une crise à l'intérieur
d'une crise c'est à dire que ces gens là
s'il ne consultent pas ils peuvent
développer des pathologies ou des
maladies sérieuses ou aggraver leur cas
alors tout à fait on a plusieurs
problèmes qui vont certainement nous
créer des problèmes au futur d'abord
vous savez que on est en terme de nos
activités hospitalières habituel que ce
soit en chirurgie que ce soit en
oncologie que ce soit dans certaines
autres spécialités mais moore maladies
infectieuses qui sont pourtant au coeur
de cette bataille là on a une diminution
de notre activité usuelles dans les
hôpitaux alors il ya des gens qui ont
des cancers actuellement qui ne sont pas
diagnostiqués qui ne sont pas traités
savez il ya à peu près 53000 cancer
nouveau au québec par année donc ça fait
peut-être à peu près 1000 par semaine on
ne diagnostique pas mille nouveaux cas
de cancer par semaine au québec
actuellement
donc il ya des gens chez qui on a mal
aux progressistes et combien on est ce
que vous avez des chiffres
j'ai pas les chiffres mais en attendant
le diagnostic certainement beaucoup
moins parce qu'on fait pas de nous on
fait pas les mesures qu'on fait
actuellement vous demander à mes
collègues gastro entérologue est ce
qu'ils font des colonoscopies de
dépistage comme ils font habituellement
ils vont vous dire non et forêts seront
fait le même programme du cancer du sein
qu'on fait actuellement
non et ainsi de suite de la même façon
on ne fuyait des gens qui ont des
problèmes importants au niveau cardiaque
pulmonaire et neurologiques et donc qui
ne consultent plus dans les urgences
harper il ne devrait pas avoir peur je
pense que le message qu'on devrait
donner à la population c'est que les
hôpitaux en tout cas la majorité d'entre
elles les y sont sont des gens qui sont
relais sans sont des endroits qui sont
sécuritaires et si vous avez des
problèmes de santé importants ou majeur
s'il vous plaît n'hésitez pas à
consulter c'est important que vous ne
l'ayez pas un infarctus que vous ne
l'ayez pas un accident vasculaire
cérébral s'installer en ayant peur
d'aller à l'hôpital parce qu'on sait que
dans ce genre de choses là le temps
c'est l'essence de tout avec eux plus
consultez rapidement plus le pronostic
meilleur et dakar est le temps ce qui
nous concerne s'écoule rapidement aussi
on aimerait vous entends sur quelques
questions aux téléspectateurs ayant une
dame qui nous écrit je suis une
malheureuse candidate ou bouffées de
chaleur due à la ménopause
7 il possible que ma prise de
température soit faussée à cause de
cette condition et éventuellement de
prendre la température de cette dame
la réponse est non parce que nous fait
de chaleurs c'est pas la température la
vraie température ses 38 degrés celsius
ou 100.4 farrell est au dessus donc il
nous fait de chaleurs c'est pas de la
fière en tant que bon maintenant une
autre question je me demandais dit
louise
mais robert champoux je me demandais
s'il y avait des progrès concernant les
tests sérologiques pour mesurer les
anticorps chez des gens guéri de lakovic
19 alors qu'elle est progrès il y en a
il y en a pas que je veux dire c'est
qu'on est encore au début de cet épisode
là donc on a des tests qui sont pas
encore homologué au canada il va falloir
d'ailleurs que santé canada accélère
très rapidement l'homologation des tests
il faut quand il faut pas accepter
n'importe quoi mais on est dans une
étape
actuellement il faut commencer à avoir
des tests disponibles ce que d'autres
pays ont commencé déjà à faire alors oui
on va être capable d'avoir des tests
sérologiques on n'a pas encore toutes
les réponses avec 7 est là ils vont
certainement s'améliorer d'ici six mois
un an
oui il ya beaucoup de compagnies qui
viennent surtout d'asie qui met sur le
marché
jean pas beaucoup de valeur mais il ya
aussi des compagnies de grosses
compagnies qui sont réputés est
actuellement développe des tests qui
devraient disponible d'ici les
prochaines semaines et qui va falloir
homologuer rapidement et avoir ce
possible au canada bon dernière question
j'aimerais savoir combien de temps dure
l'effet du savon ou du gel alcoolisées
sur les messes une bonne question ça
parce qu'on se lave les mains on se
désinfecte les mains plusieurs fois par
jour 30 secondes d'intervalle très peu
de temps parce que aurait qu'est ce que
vous faites c'est que vous détruisez le
virus potentiels sur vos mains mais si
vous vous réinfectés tout de suite après
ben vous recommencer le cycle alors
c'est quelque chose d'immédiat et de
ponctuelles
c'est pas une précaution et à long terme
les jeunes alcoolisés ça il ya une
petite protection un peu plus longue
on va dire quelques minutes mais l'eau
et le savon
c'est mécanique cette immédiat dr weiss
merci beaucoup encore une fois d'avoir
répondu aux questions nos
téléspectateurs on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine merci soirée à vous
également